One of the objectives of this lesson is to give you some tools to
think carefully about dealing with complexed, that is the management of these
levels of abstraction. So to do that, I am going to introduce notation. Okay,
this notation is taken from first OR logic. To state property too precisely,
we are going to need a little of that notation. And throughout the rest of
this lesson, we are also going to use the term abstract and
concrete to refer to the upper and lower levels of a refinement. First off,
we are going to talk about the abstract operations and we are going to use P1,
P2 and so on up to Pn and Pi we'll use to
indicate a typical abstract operation. We're going to have abstract states.
The set of abstract states is the capital letter S and
a typical abstract, typical element of the abstract state is the letter s.
And we'll also put an apostrophe after the s if what we're talking about
is the abstract state after an operation. We have invariants, we use inv
to indicate invariants and invA will stand for abstract invariants and
invC will correspond to the concrete invariants. We have pre-conditions and
post-conditions and we'll just append the word pre and
post to our Pi's to indicate. Whether it's a pre condition or a post condition,
and those pre and post conditions can have states associated with them and
arguments. Finally we'll use symbols like the ampersand to indicate and,
and the rightward facing arrow to indicate implies.